[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedriger guten Abend ihnen allen kurz
vor der Fußballweltmeisterschaft Kristin
da muss Hansi Flix sich einen neuen
Stürmer suchen allerdings Timo Werner
fällt verletzt aus später mehr guten
Abend und das haben wir heute außerdem
für Sie vorbereitet
zu spät und zu wenig Sozialverbände und
Kommunen kritisieren die
Milliardenhilfen von Bund und Ländern
Reise nach China Bundeskanzler Scholz
auf dem Weg zu Deutschlands
Handelspartner Nummer eins eine
schwierige Mission
und harter Kurs gegen Flüchtlinge
Italiens neue ultra-rechte Regierung
verweigert Seenotrettern die Hafen
Einfahrt
[Musik]
Bund und Länder haben gestern noch
einmal Milliarden zur Krisenhilfe auf
den Weg gebracht trotzdem gibt es
reichlich Kritik angesichts der massiven
Krise kommen die Hilfe zu langsam und
sei in Teilen zu wenig so oder so
ähnlich fallen viele Reaktionen aus
schauen wir zunächst nochmal auf die
beschlossenen Maßnahmen im Dezember soll
es für Gas und Fernwärmekunden eine
einmalige Soforthilfe geben und ab dem 1
Januar greift eine strompreisbremse
einen spätestens zwei Monate danach soll
auch der Gaspreis gedeckelt werden für
Haushalte sowie kleinere Unternehmen
Krankenhäuser und Pflegeheime die
erhalten zusätzlich 8 Milliarden Euro
Unterstützung außerdem kommt nächstes
Jahr ein deutschlandticket für 49 Euro
pro Monat wie all das ankommt dazu jetzt
Frank Buchwald
drei Stunden hatten sie beraten der
Kanzler und die Ministerpräsidenten
niemand werde allein gelassen so hieß es
danach Ergebnis viele Kompromisse so
etwa soll ab März die gaspreisbremse für
Privatkunden gelten zu wenig zu spät
kritisiert die Opposition deswegen
plädiert die Linke plädiere ich immer
noch dafür dass die gaspreisbremse
möglichst schon zum ersten Januar
eingeführt werden sollte und wenn das
nicht möglich ist aufgrund technischer
Umstände dann sollte die Bundesregierung
dringend noch eine abschlagsförderung
für Januar übernehmen was passiert
eigentlich mit den Unternehmen auch mit
dem Privatkunden die mit Öl weiter
heizen und auch ihre Kosten bestreiten
müssen genauso wie mit Pellets die sind
völlig ausgenommen Bedenken auch bei den
Energieversorgern eine schnelle
Umsetzung etwa der strompreisbremse sei
bis Januar kaum zu schaffen
für die Unternehmen bedeutet das dass
sie wirklich ihre ganzen Systeme
umprogrammieren müssen für 40 Millionen
Kunden neue Verträge konzipieren und die
Rechnungen stellen deswegen geht das
nicht die strompreisbremse vorzuziehen
auch das geplante deutschland-ticket
stößt auf Kritik die Kommunen verlangen
mehr Unterstützung ebenso in der
Flüchtlingshilfe es ist ja fast schon
peinlich immer betteln zu müssen aber
die Lage ist wirklich dramatisch die
Zahl der geflüchteten ist teilweise
deutlich höher als in 2015 folgende und
wenn noch weitere Infrastruktur in der
Ukraine zerstört wird kann man ermessen
was das im Winter bedeutet ein Signal
der Geschlossenheit wollten Bund und
Länder gestern Abend setzen nun beginnt
die Arbeit am Detail und damit wohl
neuer Streit
ja was sie jetzt über die Entlastungen
wissen sollten haben wir online noch mal
für Sie zusammengefasst zum Beispiel für
wen genau gelten welche Hilfen und wann
kommt das Geld bei Ihnen an all das
ausführlicher in unserer ZDF heute App
seit Wochen streiten Deutschland und die
Schweiz über panzermunition für den
Gepard Deutschland hatte der Ukraine für
den Kampf gegen Russland diese
flugabwehrpanzer ja geliefert und will
jetzt auch in der Schweiz hergestellte
Munition weitergeben aber die Regierung
in Bern sagt nein und beruft sich auf
die Schweizer Neutralität Kriegsmaterial
dürfe nicht in ein Land geliefert werden
das in einen internationalen Konflikt
verwickelt ist
vor dem russischen Angriffskrieg sind
bisher 14 Millionen Menschen geflohen
die UNO spricht von der größten
Vertreibung seit Jahrzehnten über den
Kriegstag 253 berichtet Volker
ein Leben im Keller das ist für
Tausenden bachmut in der Ostukraine
Kriegsalltag 17.000 Menschen sollen hier
Zuflucht gesucht haben freiwillige gehen
immer wieder durch die Häuser suchen
Leute denen sie helfen können die Stadt
zu verlassen
ein zermürbendes Leben unter Dauer
Beschuss der Feind auf der anderen Seite
das sollen keine regulären russischen
Truppen mehr sein ukrainische Soldaten
behaupten sie gehören zur Gruppe Wagner
gefürchtete Söldner hier sei eines
Gefangene aus russischen Haftanstalten
die an vorderster Front kämpfen müssen
unerfahren im Kampf das sagt dieser
ukrainische Soldat der unerkannt bleiben
will sie werden als Kanonenfutter von
unseren Feinden benutzt sie haben den
Befehl vorzurücken und wenn sie das
nicht tun werden sie hingerichtet
hier in der Region saporicia betreibt
Moskau regelmäßig ein Spiel mit der
Angst so sieht es jedenfalls die
Regierung in Kiew Europas größte
atomkraftanlage wird von Russland
kontrolliert seit heute ist das AKW
wieder ohne Strom von außen im
Atomkraftwerk saporischer wurden heute
die Reaktoren 5 und 6 abgeschaltet weil
zwei Hochspannungsleitungen getroffen
wurden die Notversorgung findet nun über
20 Dieselgeneratoren statt die Diesel
Vorräte im Kraftwerk sollen noch für 15
Tage ausreichen Russland setzt immer
wieder ukrainisches Getreide als Waffe
im Krieg ein heute verließen zwar sieben
Frachter mit 290 Tonnen Agrarprodukten
die helfen am Schwarzen Meer moskau will
aber keine Garantie geben dass das
Getreide exportabkommen über den 19
November hinaus verlängert wird
über den Ukraine Krieg und den Umgang
mit Russland sprechen heute auch die G7
Außenminister in Münster der Ort wohl
bewusst gewählt es ist die Stadt des
Westfälischen Friedens vom Treffen der
sieben führenden Industrienationen das
noch bis morgen dauert berichtet Winnie
hescher
über den Prinzipalmarkt von Münster
liegen
Hoffnung Industrienationen treffen
Hoffnung weil hier der 30-jährige Krieg
beendet wurde mit dem Westfälischen
Frieden im Rathaus zu Münster und
Zweifel weil Frieden mit Putin so weit
weg erscheint dass wir keine Gegenmittel
wirklich haben und keine echten
Antworten so einen in die Schranken zu
weisen das ist für mich die
allerbitterste Erkenntnis ein konkretes
Ergebnis bringt dieser erste Tag die G7
wollen der Ukraine Winterhilfe leisten
weil Putin gezielt Energieinfrastruktur
bombardieren lässt Winterhilfe das heißt
Generatoren Pumpen Zelte wir werden
nicht hinnehmen dass der russische
Präsident mit seiner Strategie des
Brechens des Brechens der Ukraine
erfolgreich ist wir werden nicht
akzeptieren dass er darauf hofft dass
der internationale Zusammenhalt
gebrochen wird und daher steht auch auf
diesem g7-treffen die Unterstützung der
Ukraine die Verteidigung von Frieden und
internationalen Recht ganz oben auf
unser Tagesordnung öffentlich blieb es
bei dieser praktisch zugesagten Hilfe
hinter den Kulissen diskutieren
Außenminister und außenministerinnen wie
der diplomatische Druck auf Russland
noch erhöht werden kann wie Länder
überzeugt werden können die sich bislang
nicht eindeutig gegen Russland gestellt
haben
Regel Nummer eins lautet weder
Deutschland noch die USA noch
irgendjemand keiner kann sich den
Herausforderungen alleine Stellen
Sanktionen gegen Iran darum soll es
morgen gehen Iran Russland Klimawandel
hunderte Menschen sind heute in Münster
auf die Straße gegangen friedlich
die Bundesregierung fordert alle
deutschen dazu auf Iran zu verlassen
besonders Personen mit doppelter
Staatsangehörigkeit seien in Gefahr
willkürlich festgenommen zu werden warnt
das Auswärtige Amt gegen das
mullerregime und für Reformen gehen seit
Wochen täglich Tausende auf die Straße
bei karac in der Nähe von Tehran
blockierten protestierende die Straßen
zu einem Friedhof heute endet die
Trauerzeit für eine 22-jährige die hier
bei einer Demonstration erschossen
worden war
heute Abend um viertel nach zehn ein ZDF
Spezial zu Iran Aufstand gegen die
Mullahs ein Film unseres Korrespondenten
Jörg Brase
Kanzler Scholz ist gerade zusammen mit
einer Wirtschaftsdelegation auf den Weg
nach China der Antrittsbesuch bei
Präsident Ski wird von Kritik begleitet
denn Ski steht unter anderem für einen
harten Kurs gegen Bürgerrechte und
Minderheiten es ist aber auch eine Reise
zum deutschen Handelspartner Nummer eins
China lieferte
2021 waren für 143 Milliarden Euro nach
Deutschland und war damit stärkster
Importeur vor den Niederlanden und den
USA als Exportland für Güter aus
Deutschland liegt China mit
103,6 Milliarden auf Platz 2 hinter den
USA und vor Frankreich Martin Niessen
mit mehr Details
dicht an dicht liegen die
Containerriesen im Hamburger Hafen viele
haben das gleiche Ziel China nahezu
jeder dritte der jährlich rund 9
Millionen hier umgeschlagenen Container
kommt aus dem oder geht in das
ostasiatische Riesenreich Hamburg
Deutschlands Tor zur Welt ist vor allem
das zu China
und wenn man sich den deutschen
Außenhandel anschaut sieht man dass
China ein Anteil von 10% ausmacht im
Hamburger Hafen macht der China Verkehr
rund 30 Prozent aus das heißt china hat
eine sehr entscheidende Rolle Hamburg
als Sinnbild denn die wirtschaftlichen
Verflechtungen werden immer enger
Autobauer VW etwa will das Engagement in
seinem stärksten Markt ausweiten
chemie-riese BASF investiert Milliarden
in neue Produktionsstätten vor Ort
gesamtwirtschaftlich sei die
Abhängigkeit zwar beidseitig China auch
sehr stark auf deutsche Vorleistungen
angewiesen aber es gibt verschiedene
Güter und Rohstoffe bei denen eine sehr
hohe Abhängigkeit von chinesischen Markt
besteht und aus diesem Grund für
Unternehmen extrem wichtig und für auch
für die Resilienz der Lieferkette extrem
wichtig diese Abhängigkeiten zu
reduzieren das gelte besonders für
sensible Bereiche wie Elektronik oder
seltene Erden nicht zuletzt der heftige
Streit um die chinesische Beteiligung an
einem Hamburger Containerterminal
die intensiven Wirtschaftsbeziehungen
zwischen Deutschland und der
autokratischen Volksrepublik werden von
vielen mittlerweile sehr kritisch
gesehen
ja die Scholz Reise wird von viel Kritik
begleitet Patricia Wiedemeier in Berlin
wie will Scholz diese heikle Mission
bewältigen
naja genau das ist ja sein Problem
einerseits braucht Deutschland China als
Handelspartner und auch als
Rohstofflieferanten die
Automobilindustrie und der Mittelstand
warnten heute vor einer Abkehr von China
die Bedeutung des Marktes sei einfach zu
groß auch zum Beispiel beim Kampf gegen
den Klimawandel braucht man China
andererseits hat die Ampel in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag eine veränderte
china-strategie festgelegt demnach ist
das Land nicht nur Handelspartner
sondern auch Wettbewerber und
systemischer Rivale und genau das müsse
Scholz klarmachen fordern Grüne und FDP
seit Tagen er müsse
Menschenrechtsverletzungen Markt und
Handelshemmnisse gegen westliche
Unternehmen sowie das Thema Taiwan
ansprechen heftig kritisiert wurde zudem
der Zeitpunkt der Reise so kurz nach dem
Volkskongress bei dem Präsident
demonstrativ seine Macht festigte aus
dem Kanzleramt hieß es heute ein
Business as usual sei nicht mehr möglich
scholzwerte Kontroversen nicht
ausklammern Peking reagierte prompt und
bittet sich jegliche Einmischung in
innere Angelegenheiten sie ist ein
Partner nicht rival klare Worte finden
ohne zu verprellen ein schwieriger
Balanceakt für den Kanzler danke für die
Einschätzung Patricia nach Berlin seit
Tagen warten vor der italienischen Küste
hunderte bootsmigranten auf verschiedene
Rettungsschiffe auf verschiedenen
rettungsschiffen auf Hilfe die neue
italienische Regierung unter der
ultra-rechtministerpräsidentin Meloni
verweigert den Schiffen bislang das
Einlaufen in einen Hafen spannend
insofern der eu-antrittsbesuch melonis
in Brüssel aus Rom berichtet Annette
hilsenbeck
sie warten darauf an Land zu können 234
Menschen an Bord der Ocean Viking in den
letzten zwei Wochen gerettet aus kleinen
überfüllten Booten im Mittelmeer von
Helfern der
organisationsschiff humanity one das
unter deutscher flaggefährt haben sie
179 gerettete an Bord insgesamt sind es
zur Zeit über 1.000 Migranten die auf
drei privaten rettungsschiffen vor der
Küste Siziliens ausharren auf einen
sicheren Hafen hoffen bisher ohne Erfolg
unser Eindruck ist mittlerweile dass die
geretteten an Bord wirklich als
politischer Spielball als Druckmittel
genutzt werden um andere europäische
Regierungen zum zum Handeln zu bringen
wir drängen darauf dass erstmal eine
Lösung für die geretteten gefunden wird
Italiens neue ultra-rechte
Ministerpräsidentin Georgia Meloni heute
zum Antrittsbesuch in Brüssel ihre
Migrationspolitik wird sie künftig auch
hier verhandeln das Land hat schon in
der Vergangenheit mehr europäische sol
Qualität eingefordert bereits jetzt
zeigt der Innenminister ihrer Rechten
Regierung einen rigidenkurs verweigert
den privaten Seenotrettern die Einfahrt
in einen sicheren Hafen informiert die
Länder unter deren Flagge die Schiffe
fahren
es handelt sich um Schiffe die unter der
Flagge von Norwegen und Deutschland in
internationalen Gewässern fahren und
deswegen wie es ihnen vom
Außenministerium mitgeteilt wurde liegt
die Verantwortung für die Assistenz der
Personen die sie aufnehmen in diesen
Ländern die Bundesregierung hat nun Rom
um Hilfe für die Flüchtlinge auf der
humanity one gebeten ob das dazu führt
dass das Rettungsschiff in einem
italienischen Hafen anlanden darf ist
unklar
jetzt zu unseren Nachbarn nach
Österreich Sebastian Kurz war gefeierter
Shootingstar der Politik jüngster
Außenminister jüngster Kanzler und vor
etwas mehr als einem Jahr dann der
Absturz zurücktritt wegen
Korruptionsvorwürfen sein ehemaliger
vertrauter Thomas Schmidt hat bei der
Staatsanwaltschaft ausgepackt für
Exkanzler kurz ziemlich brisant heute
war Schmidt vor dem
Untersuchungsausschuss geladen und aus
Wien erfahren wir jetzt mehr von
wolf-christian Ulrich
allein das er vor dem
Untersuchungsausschuss auftauchte war
eine Sensation Thomas Schmid ex-intimus
von Sebastian Kurz und sonst recht
öffentlichkeitsscheu beim Wirtschafts-
und korruptionsstandsanwalt hatte er
kurz jüngst Untreue vorgeworfen mit
steuergeldfinanziert habe kurzgeschönte
Umfragen in Boulevardblättern platzieren
lassen Zitat aus den Akten mir ist ganz
wichtig zu betonen dass ich dieses Tool
nur deswegen umgesetzt habe weil ich von
kurz den Auftrag bekommen habe
kurz bestreitet die Vorwürfe jetzt
tauchte der Mitschnitt eines Telefonats
auf in dem kurz versucht Schmied
entlastende Äußerungen zu entlocken aber
ich habe dir
doch
einen Auftrag gegeben
Bundeskanzler und ÖVP-Chef nehammer
versuchte gestern zu retten was ein
Ansehen noch zu retten ist so bin ich
nicht und so sind wir nicht die
Korruptionsaffäre ist allerdings nicht
nur ein Desaster für die
Regierungspartei es kamen immer wieder
neue Enthüllungen und die richten nicht
nur über den Hauptbetroffenen Parteien
Schaden an sondern eben beim
gesamtvertrauen eigentlich in das
demokratische System in Österreich die
Opposition fordert deshalb heute
Reformen von der Regierung
infofreiheit
Bundesstaatsanwaltschaft mit den
Transparenzgesetz transparente Posten
Vergabe Ende der Korruption ginge ab
heute Thomas Schmid hat heute die
Aussage im Untersuchungsausschuss
verweigert um sein laufendes Verfahren
vor der Staatsanwaltschaft nicht zu
gefährden er will dort weiter auspacken
um als Kronzeuge ein mildes Urteil zu
bekommen
bittere Nachricht für die
Fußballnationalmannschaft Timo Werner
hat sich verletzt Kristin das drei
Wochen vor dem ersten Spiel der
deutschen die Freude von RB Leipzig über
den erneuten Einzug ins Achtelfinale der
Champions League trübt die Diagnose
Sprunggelenkverletzung Timo Werner muss
bis Jahresende pausieren und steht somit
auch nicht für die WM Endrunde in Katar
zur Verfügung
die traurige Gewissheit wurde heute um
16:11 Uhr gemeldet die Verletzung von
Timo Werner der gestern beim klaren 4 zu
0 über Schachtar Donezk schon früh in
der 14 minute gefaut wurde ist weit
schwerer als zunächst erwartet das
Syndesmoseband in seinem linken
Sprunggelenk ist gerissen und macht
damit seine WM-Teilnahme unmöglich auf
Instagram schreibt Werner sehr bitter
ich werde die nächsten Wochen ausfallen
leider auch die WM verpassen und RB
Leipzig und das DFB-Team vom Sofa
unterstützen müssen danke für eure
zahlreichen Genesungswünsche
Leipzig muss nun bis zum Jahresende ohne
Timo Werner auskommen der mit drei Toren
in den letzten erstligaspielen gerade
wieder ansteigende Form verriet und als
blitzschneller Stoßstürmer weder im
Verein noch in der Nationalmannschaft
gleichwertig ersetzt werden kann
Erfolgsdruck beim ersten fC Köln nur mit
einem Sieg gegen Nizza ist der Verbleib
in der Konferenz liegt sicher dazu die
große Hoffnung dass es diesmal gegen die
Franzosen im letzten Gruppenspiel auf
den Rängen keine Ausschreitungen gibt
als wären da nicht schon enorme
Verletzung sorgen müssen die Kölner auch
noch im friedliche Rahmenbedingungen
bangen zu einer Wiederholung der
schockierenden Gewaltexzesse zwischen
Ultras beider Vereine Anfang September
in Nizza soll es nachher auf keinen Fall
kommen Fußball kann nicht dafür da sein
ständig eine Bühne zu haben wo
irgendwelche Vollidioten der Meinung
sind sie müssen
sie müssen sich zeigen mit großer
Verspätung war in Südfrankreich
angepfiffen worden die Kölner Führung
durch Tigges hat der Nizza per Hand
Elfmeter noch ausgeglichen jetzt soll
allein das Spiel im Fokus stehen
unabhängig davon dass die Mannschaften
natürlich mit viel Leidenschaft in der
Spiel gehen werden hoffe ich einfach
dass wir aus den aus dem ersten Spiel
gelernt haben dass es so nicht geht die
Kölner Polizei geht lieber auf Nummer
sicher mit einem Großaufgebot will sie
den fußballgenuss der friedlichen
Mehrheit sicherstellen
hoffentlich ganz ohne Einsatz hoffe ich
genauso danke Christin wir hätten noch
eine kunsthistorische Seltenheit im
Angebot gleich 150 Werke aus 500 Jahren
werden in einer Mammut Auktion
versteigert in New York kann man sie
noch bis zum 8 November bestaunen
darunter bräugels butticelli Gogo und
Klimt alle gehören zur Sammlung des
Verstorbenen Paul Allen der Microsoft
mitgründete der Erlös der Auktion geht
an wohltätige Zwecke und gerechnet wird
mit mehr als einer Milliarde Dollar wie
das Wetter wird das erfahren Sie gleich
von ostentelli noch diese Empfehlung
Christian Sievers interviewt später ab
21 Uhr
Außenministerin baerbock im
heute-journal morgen an dieser Stelle
Barbara Hellweg das war's schönen Dank
und auf bald
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter nun ist es
offiziell der Oktober 2022 war einer der
wärmsten mit dem Jahr 2001 an der Spitze
und ja in diesem Jahrtausend gab es die
vier wärmsten oktobermonate das sehen
Sie hier sie überragen quasi die Grafik
und was wir noch erkennen ist die
Tendenz seit 1881 werden die
oktobermonate immer wärmer deutlich
kälter wird es nun in der kommenden
Nacht von Nordwesten kommt die kühle
Luft Regen überquert und in den Bergen
gibt's sogar Schnee ja und der Regen der
ist schon im Westen angekommen verlagert
sich ostwärts an den Alpen oberhalb von
1200 Metern gibt es Schnee im Osten ist
es noch trocken am Alpenrand 4 Grad kühl
und elf Grad in Schleswig-Holstein
relativ mit dazu morgen dann Regen der
sich weiter nach Osten ausdehnt ja im
Südwesten und im Nordwesten gibt es Show
an der Nordsee stürmischen Wind um West-
und sonst auch ein bisschen Sonnenschein
bei Temperaturen bis 14 Grad in den
westlichen Landesteilen und 7 Grad am
Alpenrand die nächsten Tage werden die
shower weniger aber es bleibt zunächst
noch kühl und Montag aber bis 17 Grad
einen schönen Abend